some people are concerned about Tick
Tock and the influence over Tick Tock
and you know how China's using now
you've seen some articles Forbes you've
seen it maybe this is not a topic that
you study yourself no it's not your
world because I was on the board of the
Pentagon that advised the president on
this fantastic and then it became a news
story should Tick Tock be banned or
should we leave it in America should it
be banned so so with whatever other
reason one might object to tick tock the
fact that it's a Chinese company and the
history of this exercise is that China
has typically has back doors into access
and who you are and what you're doing
um that is that is a natural state of
their government to have that kind of
access to their people by the way
our companies and our own government has
kind of that same access to us except
it's our own government yeah exactly so
don't look at this is that some special
sure all right Facebook knows everything
there is to know about you I'm not
reading that yeah so
um I would be in favor and I don't I
haven't followed this lately the latest
after we've first advised Trump on this
this in fact a few years ago it was the
um
it was a one that was a brand new board
of the Pentagon um a defense Innovation
board we're Innovative things that were
happening in the world to keep you
um uh to keep you
uh to keep the military at the Forefront
of what they need to know and do so you
can have a military that is uh ready for
the 21st century and whatever it
delivers so the point is the I could
imagine just if they maybe they've
already done this I don't know
to split the company and just have a
tick tock America that has no ties back
to China other than they try to do that
they try to force them to sell right
otherwise or other than maybe an annual
you know board meeting or something make
sure the mission statements are aligned
I I I wouldn't have any problem with
that yeah but that way we would control
the back end yeah and then and then the
question becomes it's kind of like
saying to follow which is kind of weird
imagine if Tick Tock USA was allowed to
be bought by Elon Musk holy [ __ ] now
that's a crazy situation right if that
were to happen if they allowed somebody
liked him like him to buy because the
first thing he's going to do is you want
to talk about Twitter files it becomes
Tick Tock files times a thousand every
day
yeah I want you to see this so this is
uh make the video bigger so this is a
guy it doesn't matter because you're not
going to see his face this guy Neil Shen
is a first go to his Wikipedia who Neil
Shannon is he's a four billion Auto guy
and Neil Shan is being interviewed here
by
guru's Wikipedia he sits on Sequoia yep
go to right there zoom into his uh
profile Neil Shen is a member of the
tent cppcc National Committee vice
president professional committee Venture
Capital fund of asset management
association of China member of Hong Kong
uh SAR chief executive advisor panel and
Manchester
anyways
he's a very connected guy and he's a
four billion Auto guy now watch this
interviewer asks a very basic question
but watch how he defines Ai and why
China is better than us and yeah I just
want to get your reaction on this go for
it so it's a minute and a half clip in
fact fundamentally what is AI in the
whole science field it's mathematics and
statistics and China has a very strong
talent in these two areas if you've got
a smile on your face as if to say yeah
we can do that I mean I'm a prime as
major when I was undergrad in China and
there are many of my talented you know
alums and colleagues I'm pretty sure
they could do well so you've got the
talent and you've got the data is the
environment for getting hold of that
data easier in in China as the
regulatory environment does that make
life easier because in Europe for
example we have quite strict rules about
privacy and and so forth well I think
privacy and protections is always a
issue and whether it's in UK or whether
in U.S or within China I think there are
different sectors in China have
different regulations reducing those
regulations are very important and
relevant but in general I think there is
just more data point but there is surely
a danger that AI can be used as a tool
of suppression and surveillance and I'm
going to stick my neck out here in say
in an authoritarian country such as
China does that worry you at all I don't
think so watch this
could you just engage with the question
of you know a bit because it is clearly
you know to say that we collect data
everywhere but when you are not prepared
to talk about that we could make the
censorship of the internet easier
couldn't it
no
silence I mean is it broadly true in the
sin that you just don't want to talk
about the implications for and more
authoritarian Society
awkward I'll just leave a little bit of
a hole around that
yeah we'll move on
um so he went from very talkative to
silent Island yeah they asked me about
it to go off script there yeah there you
go I agree with or ruffle a little bit
of feather you know what he's saying no
no I think it's what he's saying go off
script
and Off Script is
a question that wasn't scripted that
sounds like yeah yeah but he's right
that the AI can process
information
manifold faster than any other kind of
way you would ever analyze information
and yeah you can do whatever you wanted
with it you can suppress you can enhance
you can cause people to get elected or
Not Elected by influencing what they see
what they think what they feel
and so yeah
that's a possible future of AI in the
hands of people who are nefarious in
their intent that's the part about AI
that that uh you know sometimes like we
were talking about earlier like what are
you worried about what do you think is
going to happen with this that you know
we're like oh we're thinking about is oh
my God we may lose our jobs right I was
like ah no the real that's not our
biggest problem
that's not your big business problem
because if the enemy like a China knows
how to use AI they can completely
reshape the way of thinking for your
nation by the way
by the way China has a minister of AI
the United Arab Emirates has a minister
Rob can you pull this up so these these
would this is our equivalent of a
cabinet yeah we do not have a minister
of AI why do we not have one
this is America I don't know
I mean it's uh if you visit other
countries they see know and care about
the future of AI on a level now of
course the military has an AI group that
are thinking deeply about how that would
be invoked uh on my uh board we put
because AI would come under the
Innovation
umbrella and our board we put parameters
about how the military would ever use AI
in a dis in what would be a lethal
decision
and what kind of should there be a human
in the loop the AI would not be making
that decision autonomously so we put in
a system of Ethics related to it so with
so it's not like no one in our
government is thinking about it but
imagine if there wasn't a cabinet post a
a secretary of AI that would change
people's awareness of its value to the
governance of this nation and what it
might be doing in other nations but we
haven't and we're not we're arguing
about whether humans are warming the
Earth okay this is what's going on in
America are we
foreign
what you just said
so so you're saying if we have if we had
to create a priority of what to study as
a nation to create security and safety
for its people
you're you're saying the the
climate change wouldn't be in your top
five
you you would put AI it sounds like
you're saying AI studying something of
the space no no I wouldn't rank them I
just do them all you don't have to rank
things but you got to kind of budget
like you know how you said one time you
know our budget for space is 0.4 of one
percent which is let me break this
remember the one you broke that I
thought I was like so out of the
whatever budget we got point four
percent of every dollar yeah if you cut
a dollar bill yeah point four percent of
it doesn't even get you into the ink
that's just the border on the edge yeah
yeah so a form of where we put our money
as a form of sin was the price yes of
course but I'm just saying I don't need
to put it in one place and not another
place if you can put it in both places
well if you could put more resources in
one place what would it be if you could
put in this country right now yeah yeah
um on
sources of energy that are renewable
which would include Fusion nuclear
fusion as we had the ignition test just
a couple of weeks ago successful at the
Lawrence Livermore Labs that's a
basically clean energy we just have to
figure out how to contain it and and
throttle it and use it in ways we need
so that I would do that I would also
consider turning the solar system into
our backyard because Rare Earth elements
for example that are causing some
geopolitical tension and conflict access
to them for all of our modern day
Electronics they're asteroids that have
nothing but rare Earth elements in them
in fact they're common asteroid elements
so the asteroids have pre-sifted these
ingredients
out there in space when they're all
formed and so uh yeah there's the
Breakthrough you have up there on the on
the chart so so yeah I would do that
because that has a much longer value
time to civilization than anything else
we're debating today and I'd throw in I
I I'd redouble I double down on whether
quantum entanglement can matter in any
important way and Quantum Computing for
sure quantum entanglement is that
something Jada Pinkett
what kind of Will Smith I thought you
said what is quantum Quantum entangle
it's a whole thing yeah it's it's you
have two particles created together then
you separate them you make a measurement
on one that instantaneously manifests in
the other got faster than the speed of
light so it's very spooky action at a
distance so it's a frontier of quantum
physics and it will be exploited in
Quantum Computing so I would say Quantum
Computing these are Frontiers that can
transform how we live and what we do so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]